well we all know christmas is just one
week away and that means it's crunch
time for charity organizations
all across the valley trying to collect
toys for children in need hector mejia
is live this morning with one
organization that works
every holiday every christmas and those
are firefighters
helping out hector tell us more about it
how we could help them
hey there sherry yeah every year and
this month every single day so many
hours are being spent
sorting out toys and also collecting the
toys and i'm not sure if you noticed
sherry but did you check out this
unicorn whale
it looks pretty cool and yes it's really
goofy and funny but
something as simple as a unicorn whale
could really brighten up a day and put a
smile on a child's face during christmas
and join us live
we have nino to talk about the mission
you guys are doing a lot
how close are you guys so the goal is to
raise 28 000
toys collect 28 000. yeah so we're
getting toys in we're about halfway
through our mark this year and we know
that because of coven and the pandemic
our teams had to get resourceful and
we're super grateful that we've got some
amazing partners and so
uh we're about halfway there we've got
more work to do obviously this next week
and there are a number of different ways
people can help
right so i'd love to talk about two
first off go to our website
and you can make a donation number two
is we've partnered with shipit las vegas
which has two locations and you can go
to amazon
order a gift gift card and have it
shipped directly to ship it they have
two locations
we'll make sure that uh all everybody in
the community has the availability to do
that
so that means you can order a gift right
from your phone or your computer
and have it shipped and we'll make sure
it gets to a child the need is so much
bigger this year obviously 100
100 but we're ready and we're geared up
for it and we have
had great community support this year
this weekend what's happening last
weekend you guys are able to collect
toys outside of certain walmart
locations yes so we've got five
locations uh
strategically throughout the valley
north east southwest central
and we'll be out there from nine to four
uh some locations will be out there a
little bit longer because they wanna
uh we compete a little bit on who can
hustle the most i mean that's just
first responders do that um but yeah
we'll be out there this weekend saturday
and sunday
and these toys are for families and
children who really need them
who would otherwise not have something
to open on christmas day 100
and we've got amazing partner charities
we collect and sort and then we provide
to
these charities who have screened the
families to ensure that they have a need
it's all for the children if you can
help out come on down and donate yes
help us out operation make a kid smile
right nino thank you very much so we'll
be posting all of this information on
our website and sherry
i'm not sure if you noticed but did you
even see my microphone
this is made up of a bath bomb and a
lotion tube
just found it out here and thought it'd
be pretty cool
oh wow any kind of toy whether it's a
bath bomb and lotion microphone or
a unicorn whale
why all kinds of need out there for sure
and a new basketball would go
really really far for a kid this year
thank you so much tell nino thank you
he's been with the burn foundation for
years doing great work
appreciate it hector thank you